solving energy is the most important
problem ever americans on average get
about nine times as much energy
as the median human you guys think about
certain problems that there's no way we
can solve
recycling reusing reducing we don't seem
to be making much progress that way you
know you talk about
hacking uh passwords from wi-fi systems
to
solving the world's biggest problems to
vaccines malaria
you've created some wild inventions you
and your team and you worked on a lot of
different things probably our most
famous invention is a machine that can
find mosquitoes and shoot them down with
laser beams
if it's so easy to break into softwares
to get my password
is there anywhere you trust passwords
are you know i collect them for fun
that's that's a scary thought when you
say that i read somewhere you didn't go
to college did you actually not go to
college
computer hacking isn't something you'd
go to college for it's
what you get kicked out of college for
what do you think is the biggest threat
we may face in the future
the epidemiology you know the spread of
disease dude but what do we do if we do
get a virus that's contagious that's
deadly
how do you prevent that before we
invented vaccination
400 million people died of smallpox
right that's more than the entire
population of america we want to be
ready but the argument on the other side
is
naive for you to say because you're a
scientist and you don't even know if
this vaccine is going to work in the
effects of look what's going on with
autistic kids i'd rather have autism
than smallpox the worst case scenario is
you're creating another problem that has
batteries
[Music]
so there are a lot of people that have
impressive resumes in the world but let
me read you my guest's resume today you
tell me what you think about this so
number one he
helped build spaceships with jeff bezos
at blue origin which you know just
building spaceships not a big deal you
know
uh the world's smallest pcs he would he
helped build
3d printers at makerbot artificial
intelligent agent systems
the hackerbot and he built a robot that
can steal
passwords on a wi-fi network he's got
over 70 patents
he works with bill gates and nathan
miravold at
intellectual ventures lab my guest today
is pablo holden pablo thank you for
being a guest on valuetainment
yeah my pleasure that's exciting so so
that's a that's a pretty ridiculous
resume you got there well i actually
don't even have a resume i mean those
are just that's like
projects i've worked on but i don't
think i'm hireable for any job
i don't think you are hire well i think
i think only a couple guys can hire you
and i think they have you right now that
you're working
for them so i mean you you talk about a
lot of different things that you talk
about you know you talk about
stuff from uh hacking uh passwords from
wi-fi systems to
solving the world's biggest problems to
you know vaccines malaria i mean there's
a bunch of things you're talking about
so
prior to talking about solving the
world's biggest problems i got a lot of
questions for you i want to talk about
in that area
how did you get into the business that
you're into right now
i mean i started out uh when i was a kid
i grew up in alaska
and um there was and i got a computer
when i was
nine years old and nobody for like a
thousand miles in any
direction knew any more about computers
than me so i just had to learn
everything the hard way through a lot of
trial and error and um that made me
made me so i don't know versatile in a
sense because i really
learned at a you know all the way down
to the ones and zeros how
how a computer works and then that was
so long ago that i just
kept up with it you know so i only ever
have to learn about the new things
anyone else
trying to get into computers has to has
to has a lot of catch-up to do and more
than
they have time for in a lifetime so
that i think that uh that auto didactic
learning style
running with curiosity made me made me
pretty unique and so
my whole career i've just been trying to
do new things with computers and
other technology and that's pretty cool
that's pretty cool now who were you in
high school if i was in 10th grade with
you who was pablos
i was the prototypical computer nerd so
first the very before people knew that
wasn't cool
um i was a computer nerd then you were a
computer
now did you go high school in alaska or
did you leave alaska by
then yeah i went to high school in
alaska and
um you know in those days i was just so
excited about
computers people thought they were a
joke like they didn't know
that like the spreadsheet hadn't been
invented people didn't know a computer
was going to be a
useful thing in fact i had a computer
and i had a skateboard
and people were usually conflicted about
which was a bigger waste of time right
so i was lucky
revenge of the nerds uh computers turned
out to be useful and
the rest is kind of history very cool
very cool so what what
part of alaska by the way uh mostly
anchorage i also lived on the united
peninsula for five years so
got it very cool okay so you so i'm
assuming eventually you leave
velasquez it doesn't look like you're in
alaska right now yeah i'm not in alaska
it didn't it really wasn't the
the hotbed of technology that i wanted
to be in and so
i eventually moved to the bay area and
worked on
tech startups and stuff there that makes
sense now i'm in seattle
i hope the people in alaska are not
offended by that you know because
there's a couple of
engineers out there that are going to
say wait a minute we're trying to be the
next
silicon valley people in alaska are not
easily offended
and that's one of the beautiful things
about them it's one of our favorite
places we go to when i take my family
there my oldest son
has got that personality of curiosity
he's the quiet guy
himself and everybody thinks he's weird
a little bit he loved
when we took him there so it is what it
is so so you look we got we got a lot of
uh problems in the world today i know
you gave a talk on you have a tedx talk
i think with
i don't know 25 million views or 23
million views that people want to know
this stuff about hacking
and today you know you what the
coronavirus did to a lot of people
obviously a lot of
threats came about that we didn't think
about before you know we didn't think
about
what if all of a sudden we have to shut
down i mean i've been in the states
since
1990 and i lived in iran 10 years prior
to that in a couple years in germany
we're not used to you cannot go out you
know social distance getting
don't go close to people it's at some
weird times of the last six months
but it's made us think about a lot of
different kind of threats that we could
face in the future
from the world you're in you know and
what you've experienced what do you
think
is the biggest threat we may face in the
future i mean
um at the lab we did a lot of uh
work on epidemiology which is you know
the spread of disease because we're
trying to figure out how to eradicate
some of these diseases that are they're
still plaguing us
in the world and you know we built giant
computational models for that
so for the first time in human history
it's been
you know possible for us to create these
computer simulations of how a disease
spreads and that gives us a superpower
which is
that we can now test interventions in
software thousands of times before we do
in the real world that helps us to plot
optimized eradication campaigns and
that type of technology is unprecedented
you know we've never been able to do
that but
one of the things that allowed us to do
was also create simulations of pandemics
and it's the only thing that scares us
like i don't worry about you know
artificial intelligence turning us into
gray goo
or you know i don't worry about nuclear
war
the pandemics are uniquely
advanced because of especially modern
air travel
right so you know pandemics in the in
the past something like coronavirus the
way we're experiencing it now
you know that's something that might
have taken over a a city
over the course of months and it would
take a couple more months to get to the
next
you know country or state over you know
take a while and so you could
sort of get a sense of what was going on
we have people flying from everywhere to
everywhere every day
and so um you know that's really changed
the
dynamics and in our simulations we're
able to show that
you know these pandemics go global
almost overnight
so we tried to raise the alarm about
this five or six years ago
and i'd say we're wildly ineffective
i think at that time one of the things
um
since you know bill gates funds all that
work
we have a group called institute for
disease modeling
and so he did a ted talk about pandemics
five years ago yep and showing some of
that work
and trying to show people how serious
this
was and how important it would be for us
to prepare for that and to try and
invest in
uh things like diagnostics invest in
vaccine development invest in
you know preparedness response so that
we don't do dumb things
when uh when there's a pandemic and i
think i looked in like
february or march and i think that uh
that ted talk had like five or six
million views after five years
so no one was listening i mean we
probably should have got a kardashian to
do it instead of bill
um but you know this is the kind of
thing humans just really don't want to
pay any attention to until
until it's too late and that's what
we're living with so
i'd say a good thing to focus on
investing in
going forward would be pandemic response
you can't do much better than that
um it's probably the single biggest
thing that we're unprepared for
as humans for the audience that doesn't
know who hasn't read up much on you
or hasn't watched many of your videos
can you talk about some of the projects
you've worked on like you've
you've created some some wild inventions
you and your team and you worked on a
lot of different things
can you walk us through some of them
well probably their most
the most we basically what we did is we
built a lab
to try and uh invest in invention
and really to you know find a way to
fund inventors and
and take on developing new technologies
um that wouldn't get done
in you know in businesses and
you see a lot of what we call technology
today is really just iphone
apps and enterprise software it's not
really
tech so we invent um at the lab at a
large scale i think most years
we were the uh biggest inventors in
america
um but we'd start with big problems
and so probably our most famous
invention is a machine we
invented that can find mosquitoes and
shoot them down with laser beams
as a malaria intervention and again you
know we're living with
cobit right now which might take a
million lives globally this year
malaria takes almost a million lives
every single year
and has for our entire lifetime most of
them are
kids under five years old you know uh
coronavirus is impacting us because it
finally
is a disease that managed to catch rich
people in america but the truth is
you know for most of the sub-sahara
sub-equatorial countries you know
they've been living with a lot of
infectious disease um you know first
for our entire life and and what it
really
means is that we figured out how to
solve some of those problems
in the west we figured out how to solve
those problems for rich people
and then the job wasn't finished we
didn't figure out how to
go solve that problem for everyone else
and so that's why
i fixate on um on
on disease eradication because
it's the kind of thing where we know the
kinds of things we could do
uh to make a dent in in the spread of
malaria
and some of these other diseases but um
but we haven't done a great job of doing
it for the whole world
and so i think the um you know the
potential in
in our lab was to try to invent
technologies that would help us
scale up how we could do it now shooting
mosquitoes with lasers isn't the
solution to malaria it might be a tiny
piece of it but
we also invented diagnostics using
artificial intelligence that are
you know way faster cheaper more
accessible more scalable
so that and diagnostics are important
because if you can test somebody
and figure out that they have the
disease but you can treat them
before it takes their life or before
they spread it to other people you know
that kind of thing and that's and that's
a lot of what people are just learning
about
in america for the first time with kovid
because you know we've been lucky not to
have to deal with it but we also
invented um
a machine that can suppress hurricanes
as a kind of uh
way of ameliorating some of the effects
of global warming
we invented a new type of nuclear
reactor that's powered by nuclear waste
uh that's a modern safe reactor design
and a lot of people don't even know
that's possible
um and so there's a lot of really cool
inventions
intellectual ventures from that and you
know those are things that
take a long time to commercialize you
know so
you know when you're inventing your a
lot of times 10 or 20 years before a
product
what process do you guys use to solve
problems like is there a step
step-by-step process like standard
operating procedures
what's the problem here's a problem what
steps do you guys take
to go through it you know the i think
there's a good malcolm gladwell article
about our invention process but
essentially what we would do
is start with the biggest problems that
we could find
okay right that's a little different
than what other people do
in silicon valley we have this idea
called scratch and itch
which is like find a problem you have
and solve that that's budget market
research
but the truth is in silicon valley you
know we're kind of running out of
problems you know the biggest problems
you know entrepreneurs seem to be able
to find is
having drones deliver weed to their dorm
room or something
you know we're running out of real
problems whereas if you look outside
of your world you can find much bigger
problems and bigger opportunities to
make a difference so
um for us it doesn't make sense uh to go
after little problems so we would start
with big ones and we'd take on things
like
energy or global warming or malaria
and then what we do is we
get we have a kind of a
stable of maybe 150 prolific inventors
uh from all over the world who who have
real inventive minds and a lot of
experience and
the truth is a lot of them have an
expertise um
so we'd sit we get maybe half a dozen or
a dozen folks in the room
um you know it could be a laser expert
a chemist a physicist
from the nuclear team i'm a computer
hacker
collectively we know the cutting edge in
every
area in science and technology and so
we're able to find inventions at the
borders and that's really where a lot of
the
open territory for invention is is when
you can cross-pollinate
what's happening in machine learning
with a new discovery in photonics and
start putting those together and
come up with solutions so that works
really well uh we think everybody should
do it and that's highly repeatable
but unfortunately there's just not a lot
of context where you get to do that and
so
um so that process worked out pretty
well for us we
we file about five or six hundred
patents a year that way
um and it was a way to really
come up with a lot of a lot of
inventions that that could make a
difference so
are are there any problems you guys sit
around together and say listen
these three problems no one can solve
human human cannot solve
do you guys think about certain problems
that there's no way we can solve uh well
we would i would typically put problems
into
two separate piles okay over here you
got
technical problems that technologies
might help with
and over here you've got problems
between people or groups of people
and that's out of my jurisdiction right
so i can't i don't
have any optimism about being able to
solve problems with human decision
making
they seem to be unsolvable to me
and i think it's actually it's important
to think that way like
you know a lot of the problems that we
have are
created by humans they're created by
humans decisions and by their lifestyles
and their
and their patterns and and um
and their politics and this kind of
stuff and and so no technology is going
to solve that
so um i don't work on those okay so we
got technical we got
people group or groups of people
decision making let's just say that's
political
you know opinions pro-life pro-choice we
don't deal with that but on the
technical side
is there anything you look at where you
say i just don't know how we can solve
that one problem anything on that like
bio-warfare i don't know if we can
control a buy or a cyber attack or i
don't know how we can solve you know
is there anything that for you guys is
the impossible
you know there's there if you take that
pile you can sort of break it down into
uh problems that require a miracle
and problems that do not require a
miracle got it so
in my lifetime you know we've had uh
we've needed a miracle in
energy storage okay that's why wind and
solar are problematic because
you know we need a way to store that
energy that's efficient we don't really
have that and we would love it and
people keep coming up with ideas and
trying to make batteries better and
stuff yeah
but to really make a difference we need
a miraculous discovery in energy storage
um another one has been quantum
computing
you know we fantasized about these
amazing quantum computers
people are making a little bit of
progress here and there um
i think a lot of it's overstated we're
still a long ways from
having a quantum computer from
understanding how it would work and what
we would do with it
so we need a miracle or two in that
another big one is
cold fusion the way fusion reactors work
is they make energy the way the sun
makes energy
and there's extraordinary power
available that's
that would be clean and cheap and free
almost but
we've needed a miraculous breakthrough
in cold fusion
in order to be able to do that here on
earth um
and that's and that's something that you
know you can often uh spot these as
you know things that are just 20 years
from now if somebody says it's just 20
years from now that means
they're hoping to get a breakthrough in
the next 20 years but the breakthroughs
like that don't
don't happen on a schedule interestingly
with fusion
i think we might have just got there
by miracul by miracle or by no miracle
required
actually by um by
figuring out how to take the
technologies we have and
and do it with them and so for the first
time in my life i
i've been convinced that i think that
fusion might be imminent
and that would be amazing for us because
solving energy is the most important
problem ever if you solve energy
you kind of solve every other technical
problem for free
not all of them but a lot of them you
because if you have cheap clean
abundant energy things like recycling
could work
you know things like uh cleaning you
know we could desalinate water we could
make water you could solve water
um if you had energy you could solve
sanitation like a lot of things like
that
that were held back by and if and the
way to think about this is the truth is
the reason americans are rich is because
we have access to
energy that's reliable and cheap
right that's really the main difference
between america and every other country
on earth
right americans on average get about
nine times as much energy
as the median human on earth
right we so much more energy is invested
in us
and that just me that's why we are rich
and so you know we like to think we're
rich because we're you know
smart geniuses and so that's not it it's
we're just
using a lot of energy and so the goal
should be to give everybody on earth as
much energy as we give an american
and we're not we're not getting close to
that we're not getting close
burning coal we're definitely not
getting there with wind and solar
yet um and so we need to build
nuclear reactors and we need some
breakthroughs can you unpack that when
you say
the world doesn't get as much energy as
we do we get nine times more
unpack what it means if the rest of the
world has just as much as energy as we
do
yeah so right now if you were if you're
going to add up how much energy you
you use for your life this is like you
know driving your car
washing your clothes cooking um flying
around
uh powering your computers and tvs and
stuff
it's like it's like having about nine
toasters running full tilt 24 7.
right you get nine toasters every other
human
it's not that's not a the average
earthling let's say
gets one right so that
that one is just the basics that's
enough to maybe keep the lights on maybe
cook dinner
that's about it but all the other stuff
we do
i mean i've got giant tvs around here
that are on
24 7 with playstations hooked up to them
i don't even know how many computers i
have in my house because i'm into that
sort of thing
i've got i've got you know a v8 with a
supercharger in my garage i've got you
know
frequent flyer miles to go around the
planet multiple times like i'm pretty
much the world
spent way too much energy on me
right and so you know that by contrast
you know you
if you're living in in africa somewhere
especially sub-saharan africa if you're
living in
india in china and south america you
know you get one toaster
so what i'm saying is you know
we have these fantasies right now that
we're going to somehow reduce
energy consumption you look at a lot of
the stories we're telling ourselves
about
you know recycling reusing
reducing and we don't seem to be
making much progress that way and i
don't think it's the right goal
you know we're never going to get
americans to reduce their
energy consumption to one toaster so
the right mission is to figure out how
you provide the same amount of energy to
everyone else on earth
that you provide to american and that's
how you solve equality that's how you
solve extreme poverty that's how you
solve
these health issues that are plaguing us
so it fundamentally is about energy
and so um i don't see a way to get there
uh with the with the you know measures
we're taking and with the technologies
we have we
need to aggressively invest in
developing large scale clean energy
and it's you know and my my my rule of
thumb is basically
10 times what we do now we've got to
make 10 times as much energy as we do
right now for the world
so so you're based out of silicon valley
yes i think in seattle now actually
oh you live in seattle okay so
intellectual ventures lab is that in
silicon valley
seattle as well uh that's in seattle and
i i
helped start the lab in i've been
working there ever since until this last
year
i left to work on some new projects okay
very cool so
question for you would be california
okay
every year california faces
wildfires it happens over and over
and over and over again you would assume
all the brains in california all the
silicon valley brains would be able to
figure out a way to come out with an
invention to prevent these fires from
happening
over and over again two-part question
for you one is the conversation being
had behind
closed doors and two if not why not
well uh the closed doors you're talking
about
i mean i i presume uh i wasn't invited
um but i also think the um you know
people you just gotta look at incentives
like who's incentivized to really work
on that problem
and the truth is you know it's a kind of
problem that
really doesn't that's the whole reason
we have a government
is to take on problems that are bigger
than people can really do
individually or that companies could do
and so but unfortunately our you know we
haven't incentivized our governments to
to take on those problems so we have a
real problem there and again you're kind
of out of my jurisdiction
i don't think it's a i mean it's not a
technical problem in the sense that
you know we know what to do to prevent
those types of fires right you have to
be proactive about it
but you're saying we know what to do
what what what do we do with those fires
no we prevent them from happening in the
first place by
and we by doing you know forestry
management and the kinds of things that
you do to
you have to have some fires it's the
truth like you know the
these forests were you know sort of
evolved to get
burned occasionally so you know you've
got to do it but you could do it in a
managed way
which is important when you have human
lives at stake so
i'm making stuff up here but i think
really the right answer is
you know humans have to look and say
okay we chose to live
in these danger zones we tried to make
it make it so there was never a fire
that's obviously not going to work so we
need to manage and do it proactively and
that just hasn't been happening in
california it's certainly happening in
lots of other places where we're doing
proper forestry management and things
like that it's interesting what you said
you said that the proper incentive needs
to be in there for somebody to want to
work on it we don't have that right now
place
when you say incentive do you mean
incentives for entrepreneurs and
innovators to do it or incentives on the
government side
i mean you know it would be really great
so for instance i know inventors have
come up with ways of combating forest
fires
you know rapid response uh where they
can go in
and do much better than we can right now
you know deploying water and things to
dampen the spread of fires um but
there's not really a market
for that no one pays for it in advance
they want to
so no one wants to spend a dime on on
the fire problem until there's a fire
and at that point it's too late and so
we just go through that cycle every year
that's really the reason you want
governments at all is to do the things
that the market can't do well
right so the idea is that the government
should say okay
there's no market dynamic incentivizing
us to fix this problem
um so we're gonna go uh you know so
we're gonna go invest in that
right that's why you want your
government investing in like
diagnostics for pandemics
you know that's why you want them
investing in things like you know
forestry management that's why you want
them investing in the odds of these
things i
i have an invention that we worked on at
the lab
that's the simplest thing we ever
invented and it's a way to suppress a
hurricane
right it costs way less than the damage
from a katrina or some other hurricane
but no one will ever do it because
there's no business model
right so and so
plan a should probably be like move out
of new orleans and get away from the
coast
no one's doing that so plan b
is probably also like move away from the
codes plan c or d
should be like well let's try and reduce
the the impact that these hurricanes
have and the loss of
life and the property damage and
everything that comes from that
zero government interest in that right
and there's no way that you could get a
make a business out of it because of
what's called the free rider problem so
free rider means
you know uh if one insurance company
pays for it all the other ones get it
for free
right so it's too expensive for the one
to do it so that's where you want
governments to say okay we're gonna
all pitch in and make this happen and
that's that's why we give money to the
government to do those things but it
seems like in a lot of cases they're not
doing it
so there would be so there would be no
incentive for
there's not a business model for it
because if you were to be able to
prevent a hurricane
how do you collect the money who does
who pays you the money to be able to go
whatever there you go maybe the
entrepreneur what if the entrepreneur
had the business model a guy like
yourself who says you can fix it
and through government grants of cities
and states that are affected by florida
louisiana texas let's just say
galveston louisiana you know florida
that whole area
gets hit every year how about if they
were to fund
it with a program like that for an
entrepreneur an innovator like yourself
or an investor like yourself
that would be great except that humans
are only good at doing things they've
seen done before
so a government especially is like a
think of a government is like being a
very very poorly performing human
like the slowest dumbest guy you know
that's a government
and so or at least in america so you
have to
presume that they're not going to be
able to imagine
something new right and even if it's
very simple and the reason i use like
the hurricane
sink example is it's the simplest
invention ever
all it is is a giant tube you put in the
ocean
and it brings the surface temperature
down so it can't
heat up and irradiate energy to fuel
hurricanes
so there's not even a computer chip
involved there's nothing
fancy it's just a tube it's made out of
recycled truck tires
so all we got to do is make these things
and put them in the gulf but
but so it's even imagining something
that
simple is too much for a government to
do they're not going to do it until
they've seen it i don't i don't know if
i
bite that do you mean i hope you're
right i mean if
you're telling me like if how how could
you
is there a way for you to prove that
that thing works because
yeah we already have actually from a
physics standpoint it works i've done a
bunch of
both physical models and computational
models a decade ago like it works
it does the job the problem is um
you know uh like that's actually a
really interesting one because
people always say well what about the
unintended consequences and what side
effects well
the invention is the simplest thing
we've ever come up with it's an 80 meter
diameter tube
it's made of recycled truck tires and
polyethylene trash bag
plastic you put one of those in the
ocean
and waves crash into the top of it so
you're using wave energy which is free
and available everywhere you have this
problem so the waves push the hot water
into the top that creates hydraulic head
pumps the water down below where it
mixes up with cold water blow
so that's the whole invention now
this thing will bring the surface
temperature down
on the surface of the ocean by about one
or two degrees
for about a square kilometer or so
almost a square yeah
a little over a square kilometer well
that's enough to bring your cat
five hurricanes down to cat four cat
three
right just that two degree difference in
surface temperature
because the way a hurricane is fueled is
by the sun
shining on the surface of the ocean and
then that heat re-irradiating in the
infrared spectrum that
that fuels hurricanes so if we just
bring down the surface temperature
the hurricanes don't get the fuel they
need and they don't get up to speed and
they can't cause all that damage
so you might need a a bunch of these in
the gulf
right to cover this area because it's
huge but you could most certainly
um ameliorate the problem now i'm not
saying this is the best solution the
better solution would be
to deploy nuclear reactors use wind and
solar
stop trying to um you know heat up the
the you know the atmosphere with
greenhouse gases but
um that's going to take a long time so
in the meantime we're going to have to
deal with these hurricanes
something very similar is going on with
the fires right so
you basically want to you know you want
to reduce the amount of damage you're
doing to the atmosphere
that's causing things to heat up and and
become more volatile
that would be great but that's something
that's going to take us 50 and 100 years
to put a dent in so in the meantime we
have to come up with some of these
you know uh stopgap measures but
let me flip the question on you flip the
question on you is can we create
hurricanes
we can sure you want
you want to make a hurricane i'm
wondering like
can we make a hurricane aim it in
california to put the fires out
yeah no but but all i'm asking is like
if if somebody wanted to make a
hurricane do we because you know there's
you read articles like there's
technology to be able to make hurricanes
today can we make hurricanes
yeah we could um you know there's
there's a number of different things you
could do
these are fundamentally just physics
questions and it's about whether or not
you can manage
pressure and heat um in the context so
you know if you wanted to make a
hurricane then what you would do
is um i guess the easiest way would be
you know put a bunch of coal on barges
and stick it out in the gulf
and burn it and you would uh and you
would make a hurricane
i mean you know directing it and
steering it
might require a little more uh nuance
but you know you could do it
it's amazing how to you to your mind
it's so you wouldn't put that as a
miracle required that wouldn't be a
miracle required type of
no invention that's easy to do yeah
that's easy to do and actually
there's a lot of things we can do for
managing the weather
um you know we have an invention for
reversing global warming
that's pretty simple um another one
has no business model you know but you
know i think to
to get through this period where we've
you know we've burned a lot of coal and
gas
we've really made a an atmosphere that's
not as
as good at insulating us as we would
like and so
we're going to have to do something
crazy and it means probably
built some of these geo engineering
concepts
you're saying the global warming there's
no business model but you got these
countries that are committing to
you know there's the world you can have
all these countries that committed to
i think a big number not a small number
committed to specifically
uh global warming you think there's
still not a way to fund it because the
way yeah you
the way you explained it i don't know if
those things are effective to you
i mean if you go to the you know if you
go to some united nations summit and
sign a
sign a memorandum of understanding
saying that your country is going to
reduce emissions do you think that
that's what's happening there's no
evidence that that's happening no one's
reducing emissions
do you buy it when they say that i mean
i don't pay attention to it but i
i presume that it's not working because
if i look at the numbers for emissions
you know and energy they're going up you
know we burn more coal and gas every
year it's not going down
so i don't know i don't know it seems
like a
like a bad tv show not worth watching
to me i don't know i'm just looking at
the data
i love the world what do you think i
love the way you look at problems
so so okay so let's go let's go back to
when i asked you what are some of the
biggest problems in the world you know
that you
you know or what's the biggest one and
you said
uh uh uh uh having to do with viruses
you know
another virus that could go and you know
like the coronavirus that we have
the challenge with the coronavirus is it
doesn't have that high of an
are not scored that some of the other
ones do but what do we do if we do get a
virus that has a very
high are not scored that's contagious
that's deadly
how do you prevent that why do you how
do you go about go up against something
like that
actually the way you do it is exactly
the same so let me give you another
story
so you know i remember hearing about
ebola i do
okay ebola made the news but it didn't
hit american shores in a meaningful way
right the only reason you heard of it is
ebola might get to america and then
you'd be scared
um but it did what happened like with
the first ebola
outbreak is it was new kind of like uh
stars coke two the one
we're dealing with now it was new and
um it took a little while to understand
what we were dealing with and contain it
12 000 lives were lost right
that's a lot the second
ebola outbreak only 12 lives were lost
a three order of magnitude improvement
right and the reason for that
is you know we learned what to do
right we learned about ebola and we
prepared for the response and
i know about this because our team at
the lab helped
use that computational modeling i talked
about to plot
or optimize uh vaccination
campaigns and uh what are called ring
vaccination campaigns so as soon as you
find
somebody who's contracted ebola
you grab them you isolate them you treat
them
but then you go find everybody who they
came in contact with
you vaccinate them and use and you
can stop the spread of the disease
before it gets out of hand
right so that's what happened so between
the first and second ebola outbreaks
which i think was like less than two
years
we had that much now we've lost a little
ground since then at times but
we've never had such a big outbreak
right that's what's possible
so stars cove three which you know we
could get next year or we could get in
10 years
sure you know we want to be ready
the minute we identify another novel
coronavirus
we want to be ready we want to be
testing people we want to say up
there is something new so what happens
is we immediately isolate them
we go find everybody who was in contact
with
with them we isolate them we keep it
from spreading
and then we take that and we learn as
much as we can we develop a rapid
diagnostic
right right we rapidly develop a
diagnostic that we can deploy
at a larger scale right we didn't do
that this time either
okay then we want to go develop a
vaccine we want to do
we want rapid vaccine development now
that's a hard one
because there's a limit the the slow
part of the slowest part of vaccine
development is testing
right because you really want to test
for again unintended consequences that's
what we're living with
right now in in sars cove to or with
covid what we call covid
19. is um is where the testing phase
with the number of vaccines
and we just have to try it on a bunch of
people and see if something we didn't
think of goes bad
right now we're much better at that type
of thing than we've ever been in human
history
then and with especially with the kovid
backs team like we're all
sharing data i mean it's in some sense
it's been amazing because the
the research and scientific communities
are working together in an unprecedented
scale
so we're getting a lot of uh vaccine
candidates and we're getting a lot of
testing going
better than we ever have for other
things but the point is we want to get
better at that process
and we have amazing toolkits now
you know we're doing a lot of this
vaccine development in computers
in computer simulations right we design
the vaccines
in computers before we make them and
test them in the real world like there's
amazing
ability to do that so we can get better
at creating vaccines
but we're always going to have that lag
when we have to
test it on humans and make sure that
it's fine before we deploy it at a large
scale
and then that's the last part of it
which is we need to be able to
ramp up production so what should have
happened with
with this uh with covid19 is
you know we should have gotten better at
all of these things over the last decade
we should have been investing in that as
soon as a new novel coronavirus has
found we should have responded the way i
just described and that's hopefully what
we're going to be ready to do next time
so so there's three parts i got
questions for you for
so let's go through a couple of them
here so one
i've heard that the uh from uh the
experts fauci gates a lot of these guys
it's 12 to 18 months to uh uh uh have a
vaccine that's 12 to 18 months is the
timeline they keep hearing from
everybody some say 24 months
but the timeline is 12 12 to 18 months
well
my understanding is i mean it's pretty
rare
i don't know if anyone's ever done it in
12. um but the
the the reason is you know you got to
give
you got to give somebody some time to
just come up with a candidate
so give them six months for that let's
say well we just had that six months
we've got multiple candidates
well now we've got to test them how long
do you want to test them for you know if
i give you the vaccine do we want to
wait and see
you know in two weeks if you seem fine
is that enough or do we want to give it
two months and wait and see if oh well
you know
he didn't you know we cured him of cobit
or kept
you know he's immune to covid but it
turns out we've you know
ramped up his you know susceptibility to
alzheimer's
well you know we don't want that and it
might take you know a year to
to really monitor this population and
see if they've done a good job i don't
know what the testing regime's
uh best in practice uh best in um
best-in-class practices are for that and
so i'm probably the wrong guy to ask
specifically about that stuff
but fundamentally there's that that
process and you don't want to like take
the testing process out
and so that's that's why it takes time
so we have a bigger problem in america
which is
people going back to what i said earlier
about human decision making you know
even once we have a vaccine that's
tested a lot of people
are are dubious and don't want to take
it and that's
really bad because the way vaccines work
you really need to get
to as close as you can to a hundred
percent vaccination for it to work
um and the reason is that a lot of
people can't take a vaccine
right so if you have an
immunocompromised body you're not like
other people
we can't give you a vaccine it could be
more risk for you we haven't tested on a
lot of people like you
so we're trying to save you by
vaccinating everyone else around you
and so when you see people refuse to
take vaccines you're seeing them
you know not doom themselves as much as
as the folks around them
and you know that that scares the hell
out of a lot of people when you say 100
vaccination you got a lot of people that
are concerned about that because
uh uh you know uh i want the choice to
not take it there's
i don't know uh it hasn't been tested
for five years maybe you have the right
testing for two months like you said
even you said to the candidates how much
testing you want to do two weeks two
months three months six months
but none of it's going to be a 10-year
test thing 20-year testing 30-year
testing so
there's that risk let me put this in
context
yeah you know um vaccination is a fairly
new
technology for humans okay before we
invented
vaccination 400 million
people died of smallpox
right that's more than the entire
population of america
of the united states so we invented
vaccination and that's why you and i
exist
today right we exist because of the
miraculous discovery of vaccination
so i think it's a little disingenuous to
say
proactively that you're unwilling to
take a vaccine or trust one that hasn't
even
you know you haven't even looked at yet
right
that's a dalliance for for very spoiled
rich people
i'm just repeating what you said now
what you said was
you know when you do come out with a
candidate then how long do you want to
test it for
two months two weeks two years all i'm
saying is the argument on the other side
like i vaccinated all my kids but the
argument on the other side is
like hey you know uh uh you know it's
it's uh uh
uh naive for you to say because you're a
scientist and you can say this to us but
you don't even know if this vaccine is
gonna work in the effects of look what's
going on with autistic kids
that now one in 52 and then you go to
that stat right that the same
stats you're giving with smallpox you
know you're going to get the other stat
that's come with
autism so that's why i'm saying there's
a lot of people right now that are
a little bit hesitant about wanting to
take that vaccine look i don't mean to
indict people for their fears um
i do mean to indict the folks who are
spreading fear
um i think that that's irresponsible i
think that's fair enough
yeah what i think about it is um you
know look autism
might not be i mean look there's no link
between autism and vaccines yet
that's made up but even if there were
i'd rather have autism
than smallpox all right
and if you're gonna in you know covet
we're at the beginning of understanding
the extent of this disease we're
getting better at treating it there's a
lot of things that are improving with
cova
but you know it does seem to be very
high risk especially for elderly and
immunocompromised people
so to the extent that you want to take
care of those people
you probably want to um take the risk on
a vaccine
that is has not been tested for years
and years and years
because you know you're solving at least
one problem
the worst case scenario is you're
creating another problem that's as bad
or worse
but that's quite unlikely again i like
the way you think i like the way you
process things but
you know for somebody who is always you
know trying to be reasonable on both
sides i grew up in a weird family my
mother's side
they were all communists my dad's side
they were imperialists you see this
painting behind me with those two bigs
two books all these people are debating
the communist manifesto on
atlas shrugs so you can only imagine
but you know you see a little bit of
fear on both sides they say well you
know before vaccine 400 million kids
died from smallpox
that's a form of fear and then the other
side is well vaccine has created an
increase in autism
and that's a form of fear it's just
which fear do you want to buy i like the
way you
you just flat out said i'd rather have
autism than having smallpox
and you made that decision our parents
may disagree with you yeah yeah
i can't deal with that so you know the
challenge then becomes
what do people do because everybody
keeps hearing about this hundred percent
hundred percent hundred percent hundred
percent hundred percent
that's pretty intimidating to say a
hundred percent to some people that
don't want to take it
yep right in my mind like if we just
stopped working on covet i don't even
care
right we're losing almost a million kids
a year to malaria
we're losing kids to tuberculosis we've
got
you know uh we've we literally have
um we have had outbreaks of of smallpox
i mean it's ridiculous so we have bigger
problems even than covid
this is just the one that americans are
fixated on so i mean because it's
getting them so i'm not saying don't
solve
kobe but like we know what to do make
good decisions use the data
we're going to have to write this out at
this point we missed our chance to head
it off early
we're going to be living with covid for
a long time so we need to
use our ingenuity and figure out how
we're going to how we're going to get
through it the best
now you know when i asked you about
biggest problem you said pandemic
uh uh because for me this is where it
leads yeah
it's pandemic and this is where it leads
but you said something you said
something that was like
you know i immediately went there you
said you know uh before
we had you know we had viruses that
would come out yeah but then it would
disappear
because we don't have the moderate air
travel so then i sit and i say okay
we can't control if we allow flights
from china to anywhere else where it
let's just say from wuhan to anywhere
else yeah and once it comes out
u.s has some of the biggest airports
that you can pretty much fly to any
country from here if you wanted to right
right so how much of it is coming up
with the vaccine
how much what do we do
yeah i mean a vaccine at least if you
had a vaccine
if you had been vaccinated against cyrus
coke too now
then um you would be able to go anywhere
and not catch it
that'd be pretty cool right um
but you know we're not we're not really
there yet i mean with
with look you could make if you have
healthy people who don't have any
coveted
which could be your family it could be
your neighborhood
could be an entire city you know you
look at now how
you know some cities some european
cities are doing a pretty good job now
like berlin
you know you come to berlin you get
tested pcr tested on the way in within
24 hours they tell you if you have any
any coveted signs um
and if you if they find somebody who's
got coveted then they immediately
swarm them treat them isolate them
go find all the people they had contact
with test them
and so they're pretty and so you're able
to live a pretty normal life
in places like berlin you know people
are out on the street having a good time
um i'm just using that example i'm sure
yeah of course
but so to the extent that you can you
know
contain your population manage your
population and that could be at any
scale even a family
right then you can do fine right it's
just that when you're going to be
promiscuous and have you know
interaction
close interaction with people from you
know mysterious places
then you could have a problem so um
i think that you know humans are
resilient they're going to figure out
ways of
you know changing the our behavior a
little bit so that we can
we can get by and do a better job but
you know
it's said that it got to this point and
i certainly hope that we learn from this
because it is preventable
i i agree again for me it was the modern
air travel how do you prevent that i
i i don't know if that's a you you
prevent modern air travel then you're
preventing business then you're
preventing commerce then you're
preventing connection then you
there's a lot of things that you know i
agree with you that's that's very
difficult one to stomach
i mean i don't i don't know that that
that we're going to get to that point
but we might be able to reduce
the amount of you know uh air you know
like
we were getting a little carried away
you know when i was a kid in the 80s
um i think i went out of the country
like one time
in my entire childhood you know my
daughter's been out of the country
dozens of times probably you know like
we've gotten a little carried away with
this
travel as a as a human right thing um
you know and not for good reasons we
were just going somewhere for christmas
for vacation you know
you didn't have to do that so i think
you know if you look at covid now it's
caused
that to be reduced or eliminated so so
so for me
when i'm listening to somebody like you
that that you're you're intellectual
you're in this world where to you
invention like
we talk about invention you know it's
like oh my gosh look at these inventors
you're like dude it's not a big deal you
know this is what we do we sit here and
we just kind of go through the process
and the way you just kind of broke it
down the guys in facebook i saw you give
a talk
you're like oh you know you guys think
facebook uber airbnb is an invention no
they're not an invention they're just a
business model they're not an invention
the whole budget market research go
created we're trying to solve real
problems right what you're talking about
yeah so i am just as concerned
about you know being able to
like when you said pat we can prevent a
hurricane from happening but there's not
a business model for it then i asked you
a question i said
can we create a hurricane you said yeah
we can create a
hurricane it's not going to be that
tough to create a hurricane so to me
it's like
if the wrong person learns how to create
a hurricane what can you do to use it
right
so then you go and you say can we
prevent a
virus a sars kova you know stars you
know
you're going through it yourself with
ebola first one the second one first one
outbreak was 12 000 second one is 12.
okay but can we
make viruses yeah can
can man make a corona virus
yeah from your experience just the same
way we can cure it can we also make it
yeah there's no question we totally
can't
that that that that seems scarier than
actually prevented you know
i mean it's and not only that it's
pretty easy like you know the tools you
need to do it are available
uh i mean you can you can do it in your
kitchen if you
you know if you want so i don't
i mean i i don't know i don't have any
reason to believe that we're at the
point now where we're dealing with
man-made viruses
um no i'm not i'm not alluding to that
i'm just asking that either
because i'm going to do that but
but the point is it is possible and
you know that's a little scary because
we're not at the point where we have a
as good of an understanding yet of you
know of these things that
we can tune them but it is
technically possible that on the
trajectory we're on
you know we're learning a lot about uh
genomics we're learning a lot about
uh you know proteomics how that
interacts with
your actual you know with your body um
and we're learning a lot about
uh about you know virology now and these
things how they spread
so if you put all those puzzle pieces
together and got good control of them
you could start to weaponize
um a virus and and you could even
i mean i'm not suggesting this but you
know you could
i'll let you come up with a target
population but you could
find a genetic marker for a population
and tuna virus to just go after them
right we're not there yet but that that
technology is probably imminent
um with the with the track ron and it's
not
something that's going to be uh you know
it's not like you know like nuclear
bombs are hard because you got to figure
out how to get a hold of a bunch of
you know enriched uranium like that's
hard to do
um this is not hard to do in that way
and that's why i say
pandemics are what scare us i i agree
with the way you put it there
no for the rest of us simple folks we
worry about somebody stealing our
password to you you laugh about it
because you know how to do that with
your eyes closed right with
the technology you've created so
nowadays you know you talk to certain
assets so where do you hide your
passwords i don't want to really say but
i have my passwords in my notes section
on my phone oh
shoot okay where do you hide your
passwords i write it on a piece of paper
where do you hide your password i have
it on file on my computer
where do you have your password i have
it on an excel spreadsheet right and all
these places you go through
and so now there's a business model for
apps that you put your passwords in and
they protect your password
if it's so easy to break into softwares
to get my password
how can i trust an app to restore all my
password is there anywhere you trust
to restore your passwords so let's
imagine
um that i want your password
i'm gonna make um a website
for iranian american fans of atlas
shrugged
and i'm gonna send you an email with a
you know free trial discount code
um and you click that the first thing it
says register here
here's your email address put in a
password great you're gonna put in the
one that you wrote on the
sticky note on your monitor then i'm
going to take that and i'm going to try
and log into every
every website on the internet i'm going
to find out where you used that password
before
right and when i get a hold of your
email
i'm going to click on i forgot my
password on every other website on the
internet
i'm going to get into everything so
it's pretty risky right now and i would
say
much lower risk to use a password
manager
i use lastpass
because then you'll have a different
password on every website
you won't even know them they'll be big
and convoluted and unguessable
and you're only going to have to
remember one and so that's
that's what i recommend for most people
because it's a manageable way of
of improving their security and and the
game is really just to not be the
low-hanging fruit
right you wanna you want somebody to
figure out that it's
easier to get into you know um
you know somebody else's email than
yours or whatever so
that's the game and in security we have
this maxim which is
you know if you're being chased by a
bear you don't actually have to be able
to run faster than the bear
you just have to be able to run faster
than your friends
and that's really what it's about so i
highly recommend use lastpass or one of
the
one of the password managers and if you
can get through that and you and you
feel like you got under control then i
really highly recommend you use
two-factor authentication
especially for your email and your bank
accounts um
and i would caution you if you're going
to do that try to use the two-factor
authentication app
not your phone number your phone number
is a terrible
second factor because it's pretty easy
to take over phone numbers what what do
you mean by that
tell me what you mean by really easy if
i uh
like look you i have i don't actually
don't know if i agree or not if i have
your phone number
you're basically trusting that nobody
who works for
verizon or atnt or t-mobile
is gonna take a call from me saying i
want to port my phone number
to somewhere else right so you know
i i wouldn't trust i wouldn't trust your
average telecom employee any further
than i could throw them
um so i i think and we have a lot of
cases where phone numbers are being
hijacked all the time
so i wouldn't i wouldn't count on that
being so
so rather than using phone number what
did you suggest instead of an app
called an authenticator app there's one
google makes one called google
authenticator
lastpass has one too and what that does
is
that works as your second factor so a
factor is
something you know something you have or
something you are
your password is something you know your
iphone is something you have and
you know your fingerprint or face id is
something you are
right so you want at least two of those
things to be required in order to get
into your
crown jewels because um because
passwords are
you know i collect them for fun that's
that's a scary thought when you say that
to the average person that you know to
you may not be a big deal to the rest of
us it's a big deal
let's wrap up with ai how about let's
talk about a little bit with ai before
we wrap up here
so you know you got you got two schools
of thought okay on one hand you got
people that are saying ai is gonna
automate everything and these robots are
gonna replace us and we're not gonna
have jobs
and our jobs are gonna be taken away and
et cetera et cetera et cetera
and then i heard you saying the talk
that you know humans have created
somewhere around three billion jobs in
the last 200 years right that's you said
three months have
created three you know three billion
jobs lost 200 years
but you know ai is going to take over
everybody's job and we're going to be
screwed so what where are you on the
pendulum i mean i think there's a
um you know there's a lot of
sort of philosophical questions here but
but look
you know what we refer to as ai
um doesn't exist right now
what we have is machine learning
and machine learning is giving us the
ability with our computers to do a bunch
of cool new things that we didn't think
computers could do before
and the way to think about that is you
know
before computers could really only do
things that you could
describe in a logical progression you
know if you could give it clear
instructions it could go do those over
and over and that's why computers have
gotten really fast at things they do
um machine learning gives us the ability
to have our computers
take on and understand things that we
can't
like we can't understand or describe
what's going on
in all of the web pages on the internet
but with machine learning
our computers can and so now you're
getting a lot of cool machine learning
party tricks which is things like
deep fakes and you know gpt
3 which is extraordinary is giving us
the ability to have computers
write uh write stories that are that
sound a lot like stories humans would
write
um but it still doesn't understand you
know a lot of things so
what i think about it is look you know
we hold precious these certain things
that
humans are good at uh a hundred years
ago we would have thought
you know humans were really good at you
know telling horses what to do
right and 100 years before that we would
have thought well humans are really good
at digging holes
with their muscles in the ground and
chopping trees with
axes but we don't do that anymore um you
know we don't even
do the farming like robots do all the
farming to feed us like you are fed by
robots right now
um you're basically a pet being babysat
by robots that do
farming which is fine you know
it's freed you up to do a lot of things
and what i think you're you're seeing is
the struggle that people have when they
realize
you know that they were taking some
some self esteem from doing things that
we don't actually need you to do
right so the goal of
you know or at least the goal of a lot
of people applying technology and making
products and businesses and things is to
give you some freedom right you don't
have to
mine coal anymore you don't have to you
know
grow all your food or hunt all your food
you have to do all those things to
survive
you actually get some free time and free
time is a totally new thing
for humans humans did not have free time
before the industrial revolution
everybody just had to work to keep us
all going
more or less i'm generalizing a bit but
you
and your kids have a ton of free
time
and we didn't squander it you know we
invented the entertainment industry
that's your books your music your video
games
news elections all these things that
we're doing
to try and fill our free time right
because we don't actually need you
to work now what i'm seeing
now is that you know people are going to
go through this
you know sometimes difficult question of
you know well
you know i don't need to be at work
anymore because computers can do my job
the truth is it usually takes about a
generation
like that's accelerated but very few
people get put out of their career
overnight
like right now we don't need more
lawyers we made too many lawyers
we thought because that was a growth
thing in the 90s now we made
way too many robots computers can do a
lot of what lawyers were doing
they can read contracts they can do a
better job of understanding them than
humans can so we're done with lawyers
right so don't don't try to make your
kid become a lawyer when i was a kid
everybody wanted their
kid to be a lawyer or doctor we don't
need lawyers and being a doctor is the
worst job you can get
so you what do you want be a computer
programmer
everybody thought that i was wasting my
time now they want their kids to be
programmers
so look here's what it means i think
there are a lot of things our computers
can't do there are a lot of things our
computers can't do well
there are a lot of things even i don't
have any idea how we would solve and you
know what a lot of that is around how
you take care of humans
so if a robot takes your job i think you
should rejoice
go watch a little more netflix that's
what you want to do
play a little more playstation but if
you've got a little extra free time at
the end of the day
go teach right
we complain about overcrowding in
schools
we complain that there's 30 students in
my kids class with one teacher
yeah you don't even need to be a very
good teacher just volunteer
with a little bit of your free time go
teach help us get that student teacher
ratio down from 30
to 20 or two
right how about taking care of elderly
people we can't make enough nurses
if you think your job's going to
disappear become a nurse you know what
we can't make enough nurses because we
can't make enough nurse
instructors in colleges
right the problem is we can't make
nurses faster because there aren't
enough people to teach them
right we need nurses to take care of you
because you you don't have any kids that
care about you and you're getting old
like there are a lot of things for
humans to do and we're squandering
our attention on netflix
when we should be aiming our attention
at taking care of humans so
until that gets solved i don't want to
hear people complaining
about robots taking their jobs we often
use examples like truck drivers
in america there are currently 50
000 open truck driver positions that pay
50 000 a year or more we can't make
enough truck drivers
there are no self-driving trucks not
even a single self-driving truck has
been deployed
when it does it's going to take us a
while to make
thousands of them and deploy them and
you know what those trucks don't know
how to unload
they don't know how to there's all kinds
of things they can't do so there's a job
there
probably for at least the next decade
yeah when it does
work then we'll stop hiring more but in
the meantime
you know i think people are overreacting
about these things and the point i tried
to make in that video you're talking
about is
you know the population growth curve
for planet earth goes like a hockey
stick
you know we didn't have billions and
billions of people the way we do now
until the last couple hundred years
and most of those people found jobs so
i think that we can make a few more and
i think uh
you know we need to really look at these
things and
and make better decisions about what to
panic about because you know
because uh this there's a lot that can
be done the technologies are not evil
they're not
here to destroy your life they're here
to help you these are tools for humans
to use and they're not inherently good
or evil they're just tools
so if you don't like the way things are
going
you should be helping us take these
tools and use them to create a better
world
and fight the guys who are using these
tools to take advantage of you
that's that's the game so um
yeah that's why i work on technology
because i see it as
you know the the greatest potential that
we have to
take on these big problems to make a big
difference and
help make it better for humans let me
tell you come across as such a true
believer like you
i do sound like a ranting don't i no no
no you you sound like a true believer
and quite frankly your messaging is very
different than what you're hearing from
the media because the media
is end of the world you know send
everybody a couple thousand dollars a
month because everyone's gonna be like
oh my gosh
i'm about to lose my job next week so a
lot of people are scared so
you're you're saying this is probably
not going to take effect
for a long time and even if it does you
believe in the human innovation to
create another job
so my follow-up question for you would
be what industries
like when you went to the nurse i
visually went there right we don't have
enough schools education go teach
someone
thirty to one instead of twenty to one
let's go to two to one like meaning two
teachers
to one student learning right now you
said your daughter was going to school
and there was 30 students there i think
that's one of the things you said in one
ear talks
but going back to it so what what
industry is going to take the biggest
hit and what industry is not going to be
the biggest
meaning even if ai comes these
industries are not going to go away
what would you say those are i mean look
first i gotta i gotta say i don't mean
to disparage
anyone or minimize their suffering
people will lose jobs there will be
collateral damage some people
already are having a hard time um i'm
not in any way trying to
you know make things harder by telling
them they deserve something
what i'm saying is you know when you
look at these problems
we're looking at them on a scale of like
days to weeks
you've got to look at them on a scale of
like years
or decades and you know some of these
transitions
you know the the like the reason i use
the truck driver example it's the one
that press is always using about
you know robots we've seen teslas drive
themselves so therefore 100
quarter million truck drivers must be
about to be put out of business look
you don't mess with truck drivers that's
where labor unions come from
right like they're going to be fine i
don't know any teenagers who want to be
a truck driver
right if you do know a teenager looking
for something to do tell them much
better to be a truck driver than a
lawyer
because we need truck drivers but look i
mean i think there's a
there's the easiest way to think about
it anything that's menial or repetitive
anything you can define in a clear set
of repeatable steps
we're going to have computers and robots
do that right
that's what we want to do we want the
robots doing what they're good at
so that we free up the humans to do the
things the robots
can't do and i'm telling you right now
we don't have good ideas about getting
robots to replace grandchildren
computers to replace teachers
it's not going very well so we need
humans i'm trying to recruit humans to
do these important things
right so do that
and you could figure out how to you know
there's lots of different ways that
could break down in different jobs it
could be but look
you know there's a lot of things that we
had invested in
knowledge workers right so we have a lot
of people who are doing things
a lot of times with computers it's just
fundamentally shoving paperwork around
if you have that type of job yeah we
probably don't need you and we don't
want you doing it
so look for something more creative to
do human creativity
so far in my view and i and i argue with
a lot of other people commenting about
ai on this human creativity
is something special it is something
unique
and ai isn't getting there gpt-3 does
not have human creativity
that's a different thing now i'm not
saying you can't make something that
makes you feel something i'm not saying
it can't
do a better job writing poetry than i
can but
what matters about human creativity is
human connection
right i want to feel connected to you
i want to come have lunch with you and
talk about that painting behind you and
to find out about your family
like i want to feel connected to a human
and that's what i'm going for and that's
what in some fundamental way humans are
going for
and so we have to get to a point where
we recognize that
even if i had a robot here talking to
you
just like i am and you know or
two robots talking to each other it
doesn't suffice
and maybe i'm saying there's a soul in
there somewhere
that i can't make with an ai
that's a a a very heartfelt man what you
just said right there
by the way i read somewhere you didn't
go to college did you actually not go to
college did you not attend college or
did you do some college
computer hacking isn't something you'd
go to college for it's
what you get kicked out of college for
yeah that is hilarious well very cool uh
by the way did you get a chance to work
directly with gates and bezos or no you
didn't get a chance to work closely
directly with oh yeah i um so in the
i was at blue origin in the beginning
and they were like you know three of us
at the very beginning and um and you
know jeff
loves it i mean he really you know i
mean again this is an interesting case
where
you know jeff believes in the future of
humanity
and you can see on a long enough time
horizon humanity
doesn't have a future on earth like we
are going to
get absorbed into the sun at some point
like it might take a while and we may
ruin things long before that but there's
definitely no
perpetuity to humanity on earth
most people don't get to think on very
long time horizons like that but
you know jeff did and so you know
exploring space the vision is to
eventually have trillions of humans
thriving in space like that's crazy
for you and even i have to imagine but
you know that's the vision so yeah i
love working with jeff
he's amazing he's great sensing humor
super fun
very smart all the things you've heard
true um
yeah i really loved jeff and then um and
then same with bill
you know i worked with bill on invention
and uh invention sessions and things and
we worked on a lot of projects
for him at the lab really great time
i mean i didn't personally i never had
much appreciation for microsoft
but i love bill you know and i
was the difference between the two
personality-wise biggest difference
i mean i never worked at microsoft oh
between those two guys um
yeah actually you know it's funny like i
uh
jeff is much more sociable
like jeff is really accessible and fun
to hang out with
bill is really smart has a great sense
of humor but um
his life is super prescribed you know
like
you know he has an army of people you
know
making sure that like the president's
day isn't planned as
tight as his bills like he's very his
his every minute of his day is planned
um and so you don't get a spontaneity
vibe out of bill too much but you deal
with jack so
yeah very cool well listen i i've had a
very good time spending time with de
pablo's why don't you tell
the rest of us here i know you have a
podcast coming out here so tell us what
to
expect in your podcast jetpack for the
mind you get to listen to me rant about
why technology is important
um and i'm also like digging up a lot of
the brains i mean my life is really
about just finding the smartest people i
can
and picking their brains and so i
figured with the podcast i can share
some of that you know people you might
not meet otherwise
and you can kind of see my learning
process live
so it should be fun well you're very
entertaining i've definitely enjoyed
spending time with you if you want to
find out more about this podcast we're
going to put the link below in the
description for you to go follow
pablos holmen thank you so much for your
time
my pleasure anytime thank you
interesting huh
hurricanes like can we make hurricanes
we can
can we make viruses yes we can but i
don't want to say it is and
you know technology schooling we need to
go from 30 to 1 to 20 to 1 to 2 to 1.
it's a very interesting thinker like i
love talking to people that think
in a completely different way and this
was a perfect day it reminded me of
sitting down with steve wozniak 11 years
ago when i interviewed him
and he was just like all of us a boom
and then boom boom like
mind is all over the place but if you
can stay with the mind
i took a lot of weight i'm curious to
know what you took away from me comment
below
and if you enjoyed this interview
there's another person i spoke to like
this
matter of fact i i think you i i was
going to recommend a different interview
but just in the middle of doing this
right here i think
i think it's better you watch the
interview with steve wozniak and you'll
see why
the connection with him and steve
wozniak wozniak interview must have been
in 2010 i think it was in 2010
i was 30 years old when i was doing that
interview but if you've never seen that
interview click over here to watch the
interview with steve wozniak i think
you'll enjoy it if you've not subscribed
to the channel
please do so thanks for watching
everybody take care bye